Так увесь зал підтримує українського захисника з ампутацією двох ніг.
Назар Лозовий щойно витиснув штангу вагою 115 кілограмів.
До війни, проходячи строкову службу в ЗСУ, у хлопця були геть інші плани на життя.
Війна нам всім попсувала плани. І 27 лютого я вже був у частині.
Я пішов добровольцем, бо я і так знав, що я маю туди йти.
– Я потрапив до 17-ї танкової, це наша Криворізька бригада.
Зараз це Бахмутський напрямок. Тоді ми стояли під Новотошківським, це Луганська область.
Під час потужного обстрілу Назар отримав мінно-вибухове поранення.
Його врятували побратими.
Але так сталося, що я після поранення…
Ніби була реабілітація, вона була більше акцентована на мої фізичні можливості.
А своєму психологічному здоров'ю я не приділяв стільки часу.
І заробив собі депресію на фоні поранення, почав швидко набирати вагу.
За 4 місяці - 30 кілограмів.
Через це потім не зміг ходити на протезах, повернувся додому.
Думав, що ж робити, хто ж я такий, дивився на себе, було страшно…
Вийти з депресії і повернутися до нормального життя бійцю допомогли сім'я і спорт, каже Назар.
Зараз він займається кількома видами адаптивного спорту – пауерліфтингом, волейболом сидячи і плаванням.
І вже втретє бере участь у різних змаганнях серед ветеранів.
Цього разу - у відбірковому турнірі до змагань Повітряних сил США.
Зараз чудово себе почуваю, задоволений тим, що я роблю.
І навіть незважаючи на поранення, на все те, що довелося переносити, я щасливий.
Я нарешті щаслива людина, саме завдяки спорту.
Продовжував інтенсивно готуватися до відбору для того,
щоб потрапити до збірної, яка полетить у США.
Не знаю, чи пройду, але я в цілому просто задоволений тим,
що я сюди приїхав на ці навчально-тренувальні збори.
Змагання Повітряних сил США - це відбірковий етап до відомих у Сполучених Штатах змагань Warrior Games.
Цьогоріч на відбір запросили й збірну України.
Українські військові і ветерани змагатимуться у кількох дисциплінах.
Це два командних види, відбіркові змагання з яких сьогодні відбуваються:
це баскетбол на візках і волейбол сидячи.
Далі у нас сьогодні було плавання, легка атлетика - це штовхання ядра,
метання диска, бігові дисципліни, а також веслування, пауерліфтинг і стрільба з лука.
Зі 173 учасників відбору у Києві до Лас-Вегаса в березні поїде лише 30.
Їх відбиратиме спеціальна комісія, яка зважатиме не лише на спортивні результати,
а й на соціальний фактор і психологічний показник.
Крім того, на ці змагання поїдуть лише ті захисники, які раніше участі в інших міжнародних змаганнях не брали.
Давати можливість іншим людям, які щойно отримали травми, щойно пройшли якийсь період реабілітації,
спробувати прожити цю історію, відчути ці емоції.
А це може бути реально психологічно критично необхідно для людей у цей момент, у цьому стані.
Це створення можливості для всіх. Тому зараз так і відбувається.
Ті, хто брали участь в "Інвіктус", не можуть брати участь зараз у цих змаганнях.
Ті, хто поїдуть на ці змагання, не зможуть поїхати на наступні змагання,
а звільнять місце для інших, для нових людей.
Вважаємо, що це справедливо.
Команда матиме змогу не лише позмагатися пліч-о-пліч з ветеранами та військовими США,
а й перейняти досвід проведення таких змагань.
Адже кількість поранених військових в Україні зростає,
а можливостей для їхньої реабілітації і соціалізації недостатньо.
У нас є багато питань інфраструктурних,
про доступність тих чи інших спортивних локацій,
взагалі в цілому про можливості, про інвентар.
І беручи участь в міжнародних змаганнях, і хлопці, і ми як організатори переймаємо цей досвід,
навчаємося, повертаємося назад і тут починаємо це реалізовувати.
Тимур у спорті змалку. Хлопцю нещодавно виповнилося 22 роки.
У складі 3-ої окремої штурмової бригади брав участь у боях Авдіївку.
Там отримав поранення через скид дрона.
Хлопець вже відновився і планував повернутися в зону бойових дій.
Але вирішив спробувати себе на змаганнях, оскільки раніше займався "стронгменом".
Спорт - це частина мого життя навіть на службі, бо ми кросфітом займаємося,
щоб підтримувати свою фізичну форму для виконання бойових задач.
Це невід'ємна частина нашої роботи. По-друге, це комунікація з побратимами,
так само пораненими, нові знайомства, атмосфера крута.
І те, що я вже говорив, у цивільному житті я якраз до повномасштабного вторгнення
готувався до змагань, до чемпіонату України зі "стронгу", але в мене не вийшло.
А тут мені доля дає можливість знову, можна так сказати, виступити і показати себе, свої можливості.
А так змагається на візку із м'ячем у руках за своє право поїхати у Лас-Вегас Арсен.
Для нього дуже важливо потрапити на турнір Повітряних сил США.
Бо це вперше українська команда поїде на змагання Повітряних сил.
І якось хочеться бути першовідкривачем, першоздобувачем цього титулу, цього виду змагань.
Бо хлопці раніше їздили кілька попередніх років на Ігри нескорених.
А мені хочеться поїхати на змагання Повітряних сил США.
І потім також, якщо там можна проявити себе, можна попасти на взагалі більші змагання.
Ті самі Warrior Games, де вже буде багато ветеранів і військовослужбовців з різних країн.
Уперше Арсен спробував себе у бігові та баскетболі на візках усього за кілька тижнів до відбору.
За 5 тренувань військовий зміг влитися в команду і відчути, що цей спорт - для нього.
2 грудня було перше тренування.
І з того якось пішло-поїхало. І воно зайшло, очі загорілися.
Після першого тренування одразу зрозумів, що я буду ним займатися.
Це дуже, ну дуже драйвова гра.
Мені подобається швидкість і те, що час від часу залітає м'яч в кільце.
Та поїхати на змагання - не єдина причина для Арсена ходити на тренування.
Військовий зізнається, що спорт відволікає його від негативних думок
і не дозволяє залишитися сам на сам зі своїми проблемами.
Вони відволікають від думок.
Від поганих думок.
Бо багато є різних думок, коли є вільний час.
А коли його займають тренуваннями - просто немає часу думати про всяке дурне.
У більшості це суїцидальні думки, що ніхто не розуміє, що в країні твориться повна фігня.
Типу, що ті тягнуть ковдру на себе, ті на себе, ті говорять на тих.
І така просто якась апатія і нерозуміння, що буде далі.
Допомогти адаптуватися пораненим бійцям допомагають тренери.
Вони не лізуть їм в душу, але помалу завойовують довіру і дають їм відчуття родини.
Хлопці налаштовані по-бойовому, досить позитивно налаштовані.
Але це гра і поза межами майданчика, вони дружать.
Це відчуття сім'ї, це соціалізація, це правильна комунікація зрештою.
Це якийсь такий свого роду антидепресант, можна так сказати.
Я би сказала, що це більше реабілітація. Вони захоплюються роботою, їм подобається.
Вони, насправді, хто плаває, хто стріляє, хто бігає. Вони заходять в це як у щось нове для себе.
І воно в житті дуже їм допомагає.
З 2017 року з хлопцями почала працювати.
Хтось залишився в спорті частково, хтось тренером став, амбасадором.
Хтось пішов працювати в ІТ. Чудово.
Це були "нульові" люди після школи, які пішли на війну. Хлопці 18-19-річні.
Зараз вони розвиваються. Мені це дуже до вподоби.
Останніми роками адаптивні види спорту набирають обертів.
І якщо раніше можливостей для поранених військових було обмаль,
то нині ситуація змінюється, зауважує ветеран Сергій Храпко.
Чоловік воював в АТО і отримав мінно-вибухове поранення ще у 2015 році, внаслідок якого втратив руку і ногу.
У порівнянні це, звичайно, небо і земля.
Тому що у 2015 році не було нічого в принципі. Взагалі від слова зовсім.
А зараз це просто сила-силенна.
Було би бажання за великим рахунком. Тому що, маючи бажання, можна знайти
і де тренуватися, і з ким тренуватися, і для чого то робити.
Стрільбою з лука чоловік почав займатися ще з 2018-го року. Вчився самостійно, адже тренерів тоді не було.
Власне, тренери в цьому тоді участі не брали.
І порадити, по великому рахунку, мені ніхто нічого не міг.
Мій кум, який мене супроводжував свого часу на змаганнях,
просто каже: "Я десь щось таке бачив в інтернеті, давай спробуємо".
Власне, так і спробували.
Витягли шнурок зі штанів, прив'язали, спробували, якось вийшло.
Тепер Сергій бере участь у всіх змаганнях для ветеранів,
де є стрільба з лука. Каже, важливий не так виграш, як підтримка фізичної форми і психологічна реабілітація для військових.
Власне, ми зараз бачимо 300 людей, які не десь сидять там зі стаканом в руках,
а вони чимось зайняті. Чим заняті? Тим, що їх цікавить.
І те, що вони привезуть додому і постараються, як мінімум, відновити там.
Власне, в своєму регіоні. От і все.
Для того саме і робиться. Щоб це поширювати.
Тим більше, що, на превеликий жаль, кількість поранених збільшується в геометричній прогресії.
І, відповідно, це треба буде обов'язково поширювати.
Саме, власне, для цього і проводяться такого роду змагання.
Щоб ще більше залучити людей до цього.
Це про соціалізацію, це про ком'юніті, це про спільноту однодумців,
людей, бійців, чия воля сильніша за тіло.
І це не просто слова, насправді дуже багато бачимо позитивних і потужних прикладів, які надихають.
Хлопці, дівчата підтримують один одного, в різних ситуаціях, вони мотивують один одного,
вони об'єднуються для досягнення результату.
І ця підтримка має дуже велике значення.
Сама ця атмосфера надихає і далі продовжувати, далі залучати друзів,
знайомих, навіть не стільки важливо ветеранів.
Просто щоб така була спортивна спільнота, котра підтримує один одного.
Тому для мене це як спосіб жити і спосіб нагадувати собі
про те, що життя неймовірне, чудове і воно варте того,
аби триматися за нього.